good evening my name is uh sebastian
and uh we're back with
uh another analysis this from the
semi-finals of the skilling open we're
getting
dangerously close to the final this is
the first day
of the semifinals and at the table we
have
wesley so white against hikaru nakamura
a very
very interesting game let's take a look
so e45 knight
knight c6 bishop c4 bishop c5
another fight in the italian defense as
i mentioned
in the magnus video this opening
occurs constantly at top level
c3 knot of six d3 a mainstream
theory so far of course white can go for
d4 which is like which is a completely
different story
not really gonna go into details uh here
uh d3 is the uh critical
line as you can as you can say t6
castles and nakamura opts for the same
light as magnus he plays h6 and that's
as i said in the previous video too that
this move is clever
because it avoids bishop g5 so this just
shows that the lines with bishop g5
are quite unpleasant to meet and that is
why you want to avoid them
so i'm not really going to repeat myself
too much from the video against
um geary magnus against geary so feel
free to check that out for further
explanation in this opening let's take a
look at what happens so castles
rookie won their castles uh wesley soul
plays knight bd2
again this plan is simply h3 and f1
knight sheet three
and you can play h3 if you want to of
course but
again the the difference is slight
but there is a difference so a5 and here
again there are a few moves a4 knight f1
and h3
if you choose to play h3 as i said in
the other video
then bishop e6 bishop b5 queen b8 is
the way to go and that is indeed not a
possibility when the white snipe
is on f1 and that's the case here
bishop e6 bishop b5 exactly the same as
magnus against
giri but here nakamura goes for the line
that i did mention
well it was possible in that video and
that is to put the bishop on b6
and the point of this is to simply avoid
d4
with a tempo so now black is better
prepared against the potential d4
while his other plan is to transfer the
knight to e7
of course 97 is the other option and
that is what magnus chose and
in this position is certainly a good
move too
nice jeep knight g3 and here nakamura
goes for
a slight weird move at least
at first sight and that is not h7
i think the point is to simply go to g5
and
trade away the knight on f3 and if the
knight on f3
is uh traded it's not so simple to play
d4
another possibility would be to maybe in
the future play a f5 but that is uh
that is far away at the moment you never
want to play a f5 uh
yet because you you do not want to play
f5 yet
because you are going to give away your
your light square bishop which is
better than that knight while it's
also uh weakens black's king a little
bit so f5 is the movie you want to
prepare h3 from wesley
very standard it opens up the option to
play knight h2 knight g4 in some cases
as well knight g5 now it takes h takes
g5 so we do have now a drastic change
black has gotten himself a poor pawn on
g5 which
is weak however it does give black a
nice grip
on the f4 square and nice control of the
dark square so it's sort of a
win-win i would i would say and
the pawn might be weak it's certainly
not so easy to attack it because if i
play queen h5
sorry about that if i play queen h5
then the black simply plays f6 and he
has a very nice pawn formation here
and it's very hard to exploit the
weaknesses on the
on the light squares and
knight f5 is simply met by something
like 97
and well white is more or less forced to
trade
and this is um quite good for black yes
excellent control here
and the light squared bishop is very
good and the white cannot exploit
the weaknesses on the light squares so
instead wesley goes for the more
direct d4 which is a very interesting
move he chooses to play d4 first because
if he does not play d4 first
black has other options so then you
might as well play d4 first where black
is forced to take the pawn
and we will now take on c6 and then
on d4 so if you had taken on
c6 directly
say x6 and d4 there are other options
like here
f6 could be possible and stuff because
you do not really want to take there
so that's why it plays d4 first just
repeating myself a bit there but
all right so d4 e takes d4 bishop takes
c takes d4 and we have an interesting
pawn structure
so the pawn in g5 is slightly weaker
than it was uh earlier
but on the other hand black has the
bishop pair which could be beneficial
in the long run it doesn't really do
that much now
so here i i just say that the position
is fairly
fairly balanced but things they do
change
and nakamura makes an interesting move
but it might
be an inaccuracy so
he plays the c5 here i'm not such a fan
of this move due to the fact that it
blocks the diagonal
so maybe d5 here is slightly better
the point is that you keep the pressure
on d4 so this bishop is still
good white should then maybe play e5 i
think that is the logical way to go
and then something like f5 could happen
here so black just plays very actively
uh f4 could maybe come next so then uh
white should take take and bishop e3 and
you have an interesting position here
maybe rookie ae8 here
and uh i'd say the position is quite
unclear maybe the light square bishop
could
go to a6 and uh in the future
and i like black i think black is more
potential here than
white and as i said the light square
bishop can get a better square on a6
and the c6 pawn looks weak but it's
easily defended
for example bishop c8 here and there are
no problems but by all means
white is also not doing too shabby maybe
the position is uh
balanced it probably is but i think this
is a better
better try than than c5
and we will see now the problems with c5
so d5 bishop d7 and uh
and wesley goes for for a4 he simply
wants to lock the bishop on a b6 which
has
no squares whatsoever so black is more
or less forced to play
c4 at some point nakamura makes
another move that i do think is slightly
inaccurate
and it's a very very logical move and
the
only reason is that i think black should
be quite direct in this position black
should try to do something
because if white gets nice control over
the squares for example bishop d2 bishop
c3
queen f3 united five or whatever white
is going to be much much much better
and that is something you have to avoid
you have to try to
to play actively so i think f5 here is a
pretty good move
the point is that we simply open up for
uh for the rook
and as you can see now uh c4 has become
quite attractive
with great pressure against um against
f2 and if i for example play bishop e3
which is the logic
logical move you can notice that the
pawn on d5 is awfully weak too and after
something like queen f6
queen d2 rookie 8 rookie 5 could come
and
take that pawn and this is not so easy
for
for white and as a matter of fact i
think that black is much better here
or maybe much is an exaggeration he
certainly is better
so white needs to then play quite
accurately
apparently the best move here is queen
g4 and we have kind of a
complicated position after something
like queen f8 bishop takes g5 rook takes
f2 but i think this would have been
better than than what what black did
which was rook a rook e8 because it's
not a very dangerous move it's a slow
move
so then wesley continues with bishop d2
is now planning to put the bishop on c3
we notice that the bishop on b6 is
completely out of play it looks like a
nice pawn
so nakamura decides to open it with c4
finally
opens it but then we notice that the
pawn c4 is
weak so now black has another problem
queen f3 it's a very simple move we are
now going to play bishop c3 and knight
f5
and then start attacking and the thing
is it's not so easy for black to get
activity here
and the way that nakamura tries to do
that is that he plays rook b8
quite a logical move putting the rook in
the open file maybe bishop d4 could come
bishop c3 prevents bishop d4
protects the pawn also attacks the g7
pawn knight h5 is now in the air
nakamura plays uh bishop c5
he has calculated that he doesn't have
to worry about something like knight h5
that he can he can always play
something like f6 i think that works
but he has to be careful of tactics of
bishop takes f6
they could work it might even be
possible here as well
i'm not too sure but that is definitely
in
the air here so maybe even have to
try to be clever with it and play rook
b3 which prevents bishop takes g7
because of this pin that might be better
might be a separate way to go
but you get the drill so rook e2
we are now protecting the pawn another
plan could be rookie one
but it's not so simple because the pawn
on a4 is under attack
so i think uh wesley so he just wants to
stabilize a little bit
and that is indeed a clever way to go
so nakamura is fed up with this strong
bishop on
c3 so he plays f6 blocking the diagonal
the thing is now that he needs to be
careful of those tactics i mentioned so
actually so takes his chance that he
jumps to f5
now nakamura needs to be very careful
knight takes g7 is in the air
very very often so plays bishop before
he tries to trade
the dark squared bishops bishop d4 white
does not want to trade
understandably enough bishop c5 bishop
c3 they go back a little bit
and here bishop b4 wesley decides that
well the trade is not so bad after all
and he plays knight e3 and the point is
that if i now trade
i can win the pawn on c4 so this was the
disadvantage for the c4 launch
now you would have rather had the pawn
on c5
but the pawn is on c4 which means that
this pawn
is very likely to be lost it can last
it can be lost with rook d2 rook d4 rook
takes c4
also queen e2 could come if necessary
you don't really have to take with the
knight
and uh yeah i'm not such a fan of
black's position here
apparently he needs to play something
like c6 and hope for the best
and after knight takes c4 he has queen
c7 and there are
there is some compensation it's not that
simple
like knight e3 rook b3 and black has
activity
for sure it's not it's not over at all
but
white is a piece a pawn up
so nakamura he didn't like that he
played bishop c8 so he wants to defend
the pawn tactically
and the the thing is that um if i take
the pawn right now and see it on c4
black can play bishop a6 and this is not
so simple
and well he decided that uh he's going
to win an exchange back
so knight takes a5 bishop takes a five
bishop takes a five bishop takes e2
queen takes e2
and nakamura thought that this position
is fairly okay i have f5 in the air
queen e7 and
he's right this is certainly not too bad
for
for black maybe um
it is possible to play b3 and nakamura
also thought that he's not doing too
badly here as well
like for example queen d7 and uh
c6 could come eventually and he does
have some pressure so
he thought that was was okay but westley
he plays
bishop d4 and now rook c2 is in the
air that is the point of that move
bishop a6 protecting the pawn but now
the jump the knight jumps back to
to 8f5 there are more tactics with
knight xg7
nakamura doesn't like that so he plays
bishop c8 93
bishop a6 they go back and forth here
knight f5
nakamura has has a chance wesley has
given him
two chances to find the best move here
but he doesn't he plays bishop c8
as i have mentioned before backward
moves are pretty much always bad and
this is certainly no
exception the issue of a bishop c8
is that it's just too passive black
needs to
to do something it needs to open up the
position somehow
and how can i do that well i can play c3
and i
attack to rook i attack on b2 as well
so rook c2 as a forced takes takes and
now the position
is slightly more open after something
like bishop c8
well this is a backward move i noticed
that i kind of have to swallow my
own words here but the point is that
it's at least that i want to trade this
knight and i've gotten rid
of my weakness on c4 while the b file is
open as well so this is certainly
better although black needs to be
careful of
the pawn on c7 becoming weak now and
he hasn't equalized yet that's for sure
but i think this is a better triad
than bishop c8 so bishop c8 rook c1 a
very simple move you're going to take
the pawn next and the computer gives a
huge advantage for white
it's like plus two which is crazy quite
crazy to imagine but the thing is that
black is just too passive
so queen d7 is a way to try to activate
the pieces a bit threatening on a4
but actually it's not threatening
threatening on h
on a4 because if he ever takes on a4
then i take on g7 so the queen on d7 is
forced to guard the pawn of g7
bishop a6 protecting the pawn and the
advantage here is climbing it's nuts
it's already a plus
five after the move h4 which is an
excellent move
wesley is playing brilliantly here he's
playing on both sides of the board
nakamura is simply overloaded he can't
defend everything and now he's having
problems
on on his king side as well while his
pieces they do nothing what is this
bishop doing
this bishop here is just protecting this
pawn this rook is kind of out of play
he doesn't have any pieces on the king's
side
and after g takes h4 queen g4 knight h6
is a threat so black needs to
protect himself from that he plays king
f8
bishop takes f6 okay maybe i play that
move too fast but
the thing is when you
when you are playing a strategic game
and you find your ideal
squares for your pieces you find the
ideal squares for your pieces
the tactics they show up all of a sudden
they work and carpo is the definition of
that a lot of people think that karpa
wasn't too
good tactically that's not true it was
excellent tactically
he just played more strategically but as
i said
uh when the pieces get their ideal
places you always have a sort of blow
it always occurs at some point and this
is what bishop takes f6 is wesley
discovers that nakamura doesn't have
enough defensive p
he doesn't have enough pieces to defend
his king and that's um
the case here g takes f6 queen takes h4
now queen h8 is the threat
uh queen takes f6 is a threat even queen
h6
this is very very dangerous i can kind
of show a sample line here which is
quite long and that's queen of seven
which does make some sense for example
queen h8
queen g8 queen takes f6 queen f7 queen
h6 check
king g8 and and the question is how do
you even proceed in this
in this position and
the question is simple we have all of
these pieces on ideal squares
which pieces are not participating the
rooks are not participating
so then we are going to make the rook
purchase participate as well
we simply play rookie 2 and the plan is
not harder than we want to play rookie 3
rook g3
this has to be prevented with bishop c5
rook c3 and here black has the only move
rook
b3 and it might look like
that black has not escaped but that's
far from
the truth we can check on g5 and then
play knight
h6 we're removing the last defender
and in in this position
uh black is not doing well because we
have
two many threats here for example queen
g7 there's queen f4 followed by a knight
of five
so that was a long sample line i do
think it was quite instructive
feel free to leave a comment below if
you agree
uh king g8 was played by nakamura
and again this move rook e2 because
wesley
he he sees that the knight and queen are
are in the attack but my rooks are not
participating
so let's let the rook look rooks
participate
as well and the plan is simple
rook e3 rook g3 as i did show
it's very difficult to find moves here
and uh
the plan is always similar to to what we
have already seen
and the nakamura he tries to defend with
rook e5 he wants to get rid of the
knight on f5
maybe the best move is to play rookie 7
and then rook g7 but it doesn't really
work
for example queen takes f6 rook g7
rook e3 and we're now threatening to
take on g7
so black needs to play bishop d2 and
here we have this nice move rook c3
and our rooks do participate this this
line is quite complicated but it ends in
in the victory for example rook takes c3
simply take with the b-pawn rook b1
check king h2 rook h7 rook h3
and it might look like black is not
doing too shabby but the point
is that he doesn't have enough pieces
around his king
and 97 here is a deadly threat which
threatens mate
and there's nothing black can do if he
plays king h7 we still play knight h7
and queen g6 queen g8 is impossible to
avoid
if i play queen e8 here i check here
and then i play knight f5 and black
doesn't have
enough control here this was uh i know
this is a very long line but
i think it's pretty instructive and
it's made so that was uh a long analysis
probably slightly unnecessary but you
know i love this game i can't help
myself
when i see such a beautiful positional
an attacking game like this
so rookie fire from nakamura rook e3
from uh from wesley rook g3 is a deadly
threat so rook takes f5
is uh kind of um well
you have to do that and here wesley goes
for rook h3 which i think is good enough
for a victory although there are many
good moves
taking the rook is good too rook g5 by
nakamura blunders mate but it's not
really going to help him
uh he's forced to give away the rook for
example queen g7 he takes f5
bishop d2 but the problem with this is
that i'm simply going to play rook g3
and then move my queen and now we have a
deadly pin
and f4 comes next and i will win the
bishop
and then black will be down material but
he will also have a very weak king
so nakamura plays rook g5 but it doesn't
help after queen h8
king f7 he was hoping
that vashly would play queen h7 which
would have been a huge mistake after
rook g7
and after something like queen h5 king
e7 black is completely winning
which is quite quite hilarious but
wesley of course didn't fall for that he
played rook h7
and the mate is forced king g6 rook h6
queen takes f7 followed by ricket shape
mate
so that was a beautiful beautiful game i
know
i kind of went over the top with my
analysis here but
um whatever
i this game was real brilliant brilliant
in many ways
uh i can't really stress that uh that
enough
it was very very well executed by
by wesley and um
we will now see whether or not nakamura
will be able to bounce back
yet yet again it's going to be very
exciting
to sum up i think it was very very
fascinating to see
how actually exploited the weaknesses in
nakamura's position
both on the queen side and the king side
and how
and how wesley simply got uh how
nakamura simply was completely
completely overloaded so well done by
wesley so
let's see if nakamura can bounce back
and stay tuned for more action coming
your way